oh yeah and then oh and then the best
no sorry guys
no no go ahead
you're good you're gonna plea no please
dude be be my guest i was just quickly
gonna say i put on the miley and
p davis yes that's what i was gonna say
that's i watched that too we wanted a
countdown
but the [ __ ] broadcast was behind and
uh we're like no we're like waiting and
we're like oh we got like a minute and a
half left
and someone lights a firework off in our
neighborhood and then i look at my phone
i'm like we [ __ ] missed it
no way it just killed the vibe on
everything we kind of like watched a few
people like fireworks in my neighborhood
and then we're like all right
later i went to bed at 11
and then kelsey woke me up at midnight
and i was like
ugh she was a happy new year i was like
yeah for sure but i did watch the miley
pete thing it wasn't it wasn't actually
i mean it wasn't bad i don't know better
than the other ones i thought pete davis
was pj was just funny like
i think
you know yeah i mean it's really easy to
be corny in those scenarios and he seems
to keep it real most new year's eve
things are stupid did you see buddy um
andy cohen on the cnn uh so i caught
like a glimpse of it because i was just
looking for something to like to just
like put on in the background it's uh
andy cohen and goddammit who's the
famous cnn anchor anderson cooper yes
anderson cooper and like this dude andy
cohen is like like progressively wasted
and him and andy cohen like andy cohen
tries to like make a subtle he's like oh
i'm really uh i'm really feeling that um
the little snack we had earlier andy
cohen's like snack don't you mean the
shots we took and then he's like look at
him he's hungry yeah go ahead eat your
baby food show him your baby food and
then anderson cooper's like oh well i uh
he pulls out like a packet of applesauce
and he's like this is what i'm eating
because i haven't eaten and you know
we've got to be on air all night and
he's so he's like
eating this [ __ ] applesauce through a
tube and by the end of it this dude andy
cohen has this [ __ ] meltdown it's
like wasted being like and our [ __ ]
mayor mayor de blasio just going off and
anderson cooper's grabbing him like hey
the [ __ ] up i'm just looking this up on
google right now andy cohen spoke out
after a stupid and drunk nye rant live
on air yeah andy cone regrets one new
year's eve dig cnn says tell us
something andy
watching mayor davasio
oh don't go on a ramp stop going around
country lap dance
after four years of the first half
as the mayor of new york
the only thing
the democrats and republicans can agree
on i mean it's what a horrible
mayor has been
so
sayonara sucka because you on the moment
house show yeah literally that's how i
that's how i thought i was on the moment
house show